heute live einen schönen guten abend ja
maske herunter eben unterricht ihr habt
es gelesen das ist die frage die wir uns
heute stellen und diese frage ist höchst
umstritten
seit heute ist die masken pflicht in
bayern etwa für alle klassen aufgehoben
in berlin ist es nicht ganz so da gilt
bis zur sechsten klasse einer befreiung
der schülerinnen und schüler andere
bundesländer haben teilweise bereits
ähnliche regelungen getroffen oder sie
werden sie in der nächsten zeit
einführen gut findet dass der
berufsverband der kinder und jugendärzte
erfordert nämlich ein ende der masken
pflicht im unterricht virologen
lehrerverbände und auch eltern
initiativen halten allerdings dagegen
beide seiten haben gute argumente so
dass wir uns auf eine ja doch
hoffentlich lebendige diskussion in
dieser sendung freuen können denn wir
sprechen zum einen mit dr tanja brunner
cs stellvertretende bundespressesprecher
in das von mir gerade genannten
kinderärzte verbands und auf der anderen
seite mit julia noack sie hat eine
petition gegen das ende der masken
pflicht an berliner schulen gestartet
einen schönen guten abend ihnen beiden
guten abend herr bern wir beginnen wir
mit ihnen frau bewundert ihr verband
also macht sich für die abschaffung der
masken im unterricht stark allerdings
gibt es ja noch keinen impfstoff für die
kinder unter zwölf jahren zumindest
dahin zugelassen und der herbst und
damit vielleicht ja auch die gefahr
einer neuen welle steht ja jetzt
eigentlich erst bevor warum also jetzt
der zeitpunkt dieser forderung
naja zum einen weil das sich
bewahrheitet was wir schon eigentlich
satt unheimlich langer zeit immer wieder
sagen die gefahr der kinder und
jugendlichen durch die infektion an sich
ist nicht so groß wie bei erwachsenen
und insbesondere bei älteren erwachsenen
das heißt die gefahr einer schweren
erkrankung relativ gering das ist ein
hauptargument und das andere argument
ist natürlich dass jeder erwachsene der
ist wollte konnte sich jetzt impfen
lassen und wir da also die einen großen
teil der variablen gruppen einfach
geschützt haben und daher fordern wir
dass jetzt frau d max sie haben selbst
ein kind im grundschulalter warum haben
sie eine petition quasi für die maske
gestartet
ich habe die gestartet in der tat als
mutter weil ich den zeitpunkt dieser
beendigung der masken pflicht einfach
ganz gut finde also es stimmt natürlich
was frau bewundert sagt dass die gefahr
für kinder tatsächlich schwer zu
erkranken die ist gering das stimmt zum
glück geringer als bei erwachsenen aber
es gibt die schweren verläufe und
was noch viel gravierender womöglich
sein könnte ist die tatsache dass das
longo wird bei kindern gibt und dass es
auch spätfolgen gibt also nachweisbar
schäden die auch bei milden verläufen im
körper passieren und von denen die
konsequenzen tatsächlich noch nicht
absehbar sind also der grund warum
das ist der grund warum wir die kinder
einfach schützen müssten wir haben nicht
im moment haben wir nicht viel mehr als
die maske bei den kleinsten dass die
eingangs date man sozusagen also da
haben wir schon gesehen da prallen zwei
positionen aufeinander diese
entgegengesetzt sind diese diskussion
ist allerdings schon ein bisschen älter
mein kollege moritz neues bringt uns
noch mal auf den stand der dinge was ich
da auch in den letzten tagen
insbesondere getan hat
viele kinder und jugendliche müssen oft
stundenlang pauken mit maske feiern ohne
maske dürfen dagegen oft ältere
ungerecht findet der ärztepräsident
im jetzigen zeitpunkt wo wir in der
gastronomie im theater im kino auch im
büro am platz als erwachsene keine maske
getragen
unangemessen und nicht mehr angebracht
und die kinder nicht mehr zumutbar und
aus diesem grunde plädiere ich dafür
dass maske tragen während des
unterrichts am platz für die schüler
aufheben denn kinder seien eben keine
pandemie treiber erkrankungen bei ihnen
seltener und weniger schwer die
hospitalisierung rate beträgt bei den
fünf bis 14 jährigen aktuell 0,48 der
niedrigste wert aller altersstufen
umgekehrt ist es aber bei den
infektionen die sieben tage incidents
ist mit 152,5 die höchste der
lehrerverband ruft zur vorsicht auf
eigentlich hoffen natürlich alle dass
irgendwann mal die masken fallen werden
wir glauben aber das ist der falsche
zeitpunkt ist die virologen warnen vor
einer großen vierten welle die sich
verschärfen wird und da jetzt sozusagen
die masken pflicht abzuschaffen halten
wir für voreilig besser vorsichtig sein
sagt auch virologin brinkmann und zur
lockerung der masken pflicht an schulen
bei der hohen anzahl an nicht geimpften
und hierzu zählen die kinder halte ich
diese entscheidung für verfrüht und
ehrlich gesagt auch für ziemlich dumm
die debatte erhitzt auch bei twitter
äußern sich viele user unter dem hashtag
die maske bleibt auf wir hatten
eineinhalb jahre schulen nachhaltig zu
verbessern durch luftfilter und
digitales lernen und jetzt sollen kinder
die nichts davon erhalten haben keine
masken mehr tragen weil ihre eltern ja
auch ohne maske ins café dürfen und dann
ist das ungerecht ungeimpfte kinder
schreibt dieser user haben ein
geringeres sterblichkeitsrisiko durch ko
wird als ihre geimpften lehrer die maske
bleibt auf macht keinen sinn mit der
maske viele der letzte schutz an schulen
weg kein abstand keine impfung unter
zwölf kaum luftfilter das motto kann
daher nur lauten die maske bleibt auf
der herbst ist da und mit ihm die
ungewissheit wie es weitergeht in der
pandemie
also da waren jetzt schon jede menge
argumente für beide seiten enthalten in
diesen beitrag frau brunnert also fangen
wir mal an vielleicht mit ihrer kollegin
im weiteren sinne virologin melanie
brinkmann sie sagt die abschaffung der
masken pflicht sei verfrüht und deswegen
auch dumm das tragen der maske haben
sich erwiesenermaßen als sinnvoll bzw
auch effektiv herausgestellt was sagen
sie dazu
naja es war jetzt tatsächlich dumm zu
behaupten dass die maske nicht effektiv
gewesen ist im schutz mich also das ist
ja auch nichts was irgendwie bestritten
wird aber wir sind jetzt an einem punkt
angekommen ich hab das eben schon mal
gesagt die wollen gruppen sind geschützt
insbesondere hat die älteren natürlich
nur die über zwölf das muss man auch
ganz klar zur kenntnis nehmen und
es ist einfach so natürlich haben wir
eine unheimlich hohe inzidenz in dieser
altersgruppe aber da muss man natürlich
auch ganz klar sagen welche altersgruppe
wird dennoch so häufig getestet wie die
der schüler innen also keine andere ja
und natürlich ist auch das ein faktor
weshalb er so hohe inzidenz ermessen ob
das immer krankheitswert hat das sehen
wir sehr sieben tage incidents nicht an
und das ist einfach der grund weshalb
wir sagen ja wir wissen dass das ist ja
nichts was unbekannt ist und trotzdem
die infektiosität die von jüngeren
schüler innen insbesondere aus geht es
überhaupt nicht mit der vergleichbar
eines erwachsenen die ist geringer die
krankheitslast ist es sowieso und
deswegen können wir das verantworten und
wie schon immer in der pandemie muss man
ja ganz ehrlich sagen natürlich ist es
so wir fällen entscheidungen und unter
umständen müssen wir im verlauf darüber
nachdenken ist es die richtige
entscheidung gewesen das war jetzt aber
bisher auch noch nie anders und wir
halten es trotzdem für den richtigen
zeitpunkt jetzt zu sagen
altersabhängig incidents abhängig muss
jetzt auch bei den schülern die maske
fallen von joerg also geringe verläufe
wir haben es gerade noch mal von frau dr
brunnert gehört warum kann sie dieses
argument nicht wirklich beruhigen
das kann ich deshalb nicht beruhigen
weil
wie ich ja eben auch schon sagt die
krankheit schwerer im sinne von schwere
verläufe
ist in der tat geringer was nicht
geringer ist das hat man an
verschiedenen mehreren studien gesehen
ist die infektiosität also kinder
stecken sich genauso an und sind auch
genauso ansteckend wie erwachsene
natürlich ist die inzidenz
auch ein bisschen los koppel bar von der
von von den fällen die dann schwer
werden das ist ja mittlerweile bei der
geimpften erwachsenen bevölkerung auch
so aber wie gesagt erstens es gibt
schwere verläufe bei kindern das ist
unumstritten es sind zum beispiel es
werden die krankenhaus die
hospitalisierung rate liegt bei einem
prozent manchmal bei 2 prozent die
berliner kliniken kinderkliniken sind
zum teil jetzt schon nicht von kogit
fällen aber einfach durch einen mangel
an pflegekräften und ich weiß nicht was
überlastet und vor allen dingen gibt es
wie gesagt die gefahr von long beach das
ist mittlerweile auch nichts mehr was es
wird leider immer noch geleugnet es
dürfte aber nicht mehr geleugnet werden
also man weiß dass also aktuell gibt es
in großbritannien sechs bis acht prozent
der infizierten kinder die an langkow
fitline ja wenn wir das nur zum beispiel
auf
nordrhein-westfalen glaube ich sollte
jetzt auch den masken pflicht das ja
auch angedacht von der frau gebauer wenn
wir das mal auf nordrhein-westfalen
hochrechnen würden da gab es bis
235.000 fälle von infizierten kinder die
meisten davon zum glück mit milden
verlauf aber das würde bedeuten dass
dort wenn wir zwischen sechs und acht
prozent kommen konservativ 7 prozent
sagen hätten 10.000 kinder würden schon
lankowitz symptome entwickeln oder doch
mal eine hatten nur nur sag ich mal das
ja weil das ist ja ein wichtiges
stichwort lankowitz war jetzt auch schon
länger in der diskussion da würde ich
jetzt gerne auch noch mal die
einschätzung der gegenposition ab wohl
nicht meiner kann man jetzt vielleicht
sagen es betrifft nicht viele aber jeder
fall ist vielleicht auch einer zuviel
oder definitiv einer zuviel verwundert
ja also natürlich ist das so also das
wäre ja sehr komisch wenn wir als
kinderärztin nicht die augen davor
verschließen würden dass es schwere
verläufe von erkrankungen gibt natürlich
ist uns das bekannt dass es diese
schweren verläufe gibt es gibt das pins
es gibt das longo wie niemand bestreitet
dass die häufigkeit würde ich anzweifeln
und es ist tatsächlich so also eine
kleine anekdote heute hat das zdf
angefragt weil es gerne auch einen
beitrag über ein kind mit lankowitz
machen ich frage im moment bei meinen
kolleginnen in niedersachsen rum bisher
habe ich noch niemanden gefunden der
patienten betreut also es ist so ja
natürlich das gibt es aber es ist extrem
selten
und ja das gibt es aber bei vielen
anderen viruserkrankungen auch franz sie
haben es ja eben schon gesagt die
kinderkliniken sind voll sie sind voll
mit anderen infekten sie sind voll wir
haben viele kinder jetzt mit rs virus
infektionen die bei den jüngeren kindern
ja das wissen wir dass es auch nichts
neues aber in der häufigkeit und in der
frühe des jahres ist es neu schwer
verlaufen können und natürlich sie haben
total reicht es wird uns auf die füße
fallen dass wir viel zu wenig betten in
den kinderkliniken vorhaben die sind da
das ist eine politische entscheidung
gewesen das wird ein problem werden aber
es hat überhaupt nichts mit den corona
infektionen zu tun und ja es gibt
natürlich auch aus metallisierung raten
von corona infizierten kinder das
betrifft vor allen dingen die sehr
kleinen kinder und die aber trotzdem
auch mit einem guten auto kam und
deswegen da darf man jetzt verschiedene
dinge nicht miteinander vermengen und
dass die kinder so viele andere infekte
haben jetzt und in dieser wucht in der
diese infekt werde die nichts mit corona
zu tun hat im moment über uns
hereinbricht hat etwas damit zu tun dass
wir die kinder extrem von infekten
ferngehalten haben jetzt über anderthalb
jahre und es so was wie so ein aufholen
bei diesen infekten gibt und da muss man
sich dann auch fragen ja
natürlich war das richtig dass wir das
gemacht haben aber das ist jetzt eine
folge die wir davon sehen mit der wir
auch klar kommen müssen und die kinder
auch klarkommen ist also jetzt insgesamt
ein höheres infektionsgeschehen auch als
folge des maske tragen und ihr abstand
halten das habe ich das richtig
verstanden
naja also sie ist jeder weiß es aus der
eigenen erfahrung wir haben kaum infekte
gehabt in den letzten anderthalb jahren
also auch keine banale infekte
wir hatten kein mal schnupfen wir hatten
keine grippewelle wir hatten kein magen
darm das ist alles ferngehalten worden
von uns natürlich auch ein
resultat der hervorragend könnten
pastilla der schutzwirkung einer maske
tröpfchen infektion verhindert man damit
hervorragend das wissen wir ja ich aber
das holen die kinder jetzt nach noch
ganz kurz vor bruder hat frau noah
glaube ich möchte erwidern
genau ich wollte und wollte zunächst
sagen dass ich das als ich sagte die
kinder krankenhäuser in berlin sind voll
damit meine ich nicht mit kurven voll
das ist schon klar dass das im moment
andere infekte sind nur
wenn die masten jetzt fallen was meinen
sie wieder an die infektionszahlen
hochsteigen im jetzt kommenden herbst
und winter es ist ja nun mal so dass wir
es mit einem virus zu tun haben denen es
relativ egal ist wo es gerade ist wo es
sich verbreitet ist verbreitet sich da
wo es kann und in
geschlossenen räumen wo viele menschen
auf einem haufen sind verbreitet sich
dieses virus und das ist das gleiche in
kneipen oder clubs wie in schulen oder
auf irgendwelchen konferenzen der
unterschied zu knallten und konferenzen
ist dass die menschen da schon geimpft
sind und an den schulen sind die unter
zwölfjährigen noch nicht gehen dann
möchte ich auch noch eben was sagen
zudem dass immer wieder gesagt wird
longo wird ist extrem selten longo wird
ist nicht extrem selten ich habe eben
schon ein paar zahlen genannt in jena in
münchen und in augsburg wurden jetzt die
ersten longo wird ambulanzen
eingerichtet großbritannien hat 118
millionen euro ausgegeben um 16
pädiatrische zentren für die versorgung
von corona langzeitschäden und keine
folgeschäden bei kindern zu behandeln
das ist nicht extrem selten und auf
einfache möchte ich auch zu sprechen vom
jahr aber
noch diesen angesagten auch alles
ich sehe sie leider nicht aber
longo wird ist ja dass ich sie auch sein
mag ich sie beide seiten sind thematisch
gut also longo wird ist das was dann
symptomatisch zum vorschein kommt anhand
von verschiedenen beschwerden von
müdigkeit dieses chronic fatigue syndrom
das wünscht sich niemand für sein kind
aber und das wird komischerweise auch in
den medien geht geht völlig unter es
gibt mittlerweile
nachweisbare auch durch biomarker
nachweisbare schäden im körper die
erstmal nicht symptomatisch sind es gibt
zum beispiel kann man im blut
untersuchungen von forfour zuvor
infizierten kindern sehen da ist die
konzentration von
so eine marke der gefäßentzündungen und
mikro thrombosen anzeigte ist sechs bis
zehn fach erhöht es gibt bereiche im
hirn die geschädigt sind das konnte
jetzt erstmals nachgewiesen werden durch
dann durch das pet ct verfahren ist ein
bildgebendes verfahren da sind
hirnregionen da ist der stoffwechsel der
zuckerstoffwechsel der dose stoffwechsel
im hirn ist geschädigt und das sind
sachen von denen wir noch gar nicht
wissen was in fünf oder zehn oder 15
jahren daraus wird bei der masern
erkrankungen ja
ist diese ganz schreckliche post
enzephalitis tritt bis zu zehn jahre
nach der aktuellen infektion auf und wir
haben es hier und das wusste man auch
erst spät das hat man erst nach vielen
jahren studien herausgefunden
und wir haben es hier mit einem virus zu
tun das ganz neu ist und solange wir
einfach nicht ausschließen können dass
es auch langen zeit gefahren gibt für
unsere kinder müssen wir doch die
vorsichtsmaßnahme fahren und worüber
reden wir denn hier wir reden über also
was liegt auf der waagschale das eine
ist die maske die ist nicht schön die
macht keinen spaß wie es unbequem dies
lässt sich alles klar und auf der
anderen seite liegt wirklich die gefahr
eines noch völlig unerforschten virus
und das wenige wochen wahrscheinlich
bevor auch die kleinsten impfangebot
bekommen haben ich glaube
ja der punkt glaube ich ist gut
rübergekommen also der zeitpunkt man
könnte jetzt ja auch sagen okay es wird
wohl nicht mehr lange dauern bis es dann
auch eine impfstoff für die unter
zwölfjährigen gibt warum nicht noch ein
wenig warten die frage stellt sich doch
in der tat
ja natürlich stellt sich die frage also
am freitag hat es ja schon gesagt wir
haben das mit post kubik longo wie zu
tun ob es immer die folge der infektion
ist was wir da sehen bei den kindern und
jugendlichen das ist wirklich die ganz
interessante frage ja also die
ambulanzen füllen sich tatsächlich mit
kindern mit fertig mit erschöpfung mit
depressionen auch mit vielen folge
erkrankungen der korona pandemie aber ob
es immer eine folge der infektion ist
das ist wirklich die große frage und ja
natürlich haben sie recht frau noch das
kann ich ja auch überhaupt nicht in
frage stellen wir wissen heute nicht was
das virus in zehn jahren mit uns macht
wir wissen aber was das virus im moment
mit unseren kindern und jugendlichen
macht und das macht uns halt einfach
immense sorgen und natürlich ist es so
sie haben recht die maske ist für viele
kinder jetzt nicht besonders
einschränkend und warum wollen wir jetzt
nicht warten wenn doch unter umständen
die zulassung der impfung kurz vor der
tür steht ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
wirklich in der altersgruppe 5 bis 11
das ist ja die eu jetzt die zulassung
unter umständen demnächst kommt die
beantragt ist die impfbereitschaft
wirklich genauso groß ist wie sie von
unseren jugendlichen ist das muss man ja
sagen das ist etwas da kann man wirklich
nur den hut vor
impfen lassen
da will ich gerne auch mal kurz rein
haken das wundert auch mittel noch mal
ganz kurz die nachfrage erlauben sie mir
sie haben gerade angesprochen dass das
ja nicht der einzige punkt ist sozusagen
auf dem man schauen muss das maß
getragen hätte auch noch andere folgen
habe ich jetzt ihrer aussage entnommen
sie sagen auch als verband dass sie
einen ganzheitlichen blick auf die
kinder haben was meinen sie denn damit
genau welche folgen beobachten sie auf
die es jetzt auch noch ankommt
na ja also das was ich im prinzip eben
schon aufgezählt haben wir sehen schon
unheimlich viele emotionale
beeinträchtigungen der kinder und
jugendlichen und letztlich ist dass das
was uns im moment die größere sorge
macht und
das sind halt tatsächlich diese dinge
die dem den post kopitz und um den long
beach und rom sehr ähnlich sind das
macht es ja so schwierig das auch gut
auseinander zu halten und
dass die andere frage war ja was machen
jetzt mit der impfung und warum wollen
wir das jetzt und warum wollen wir nicht
abwarten ich finde es ist jetzt noch
nicht abschließend beantwortet denn man
muss ganz klar sagen dass wir jetzt
wirklich alle kinder durch geimpft haben
das wird ja eine noch unheimlich lange
zeit dauern und es ist einfach für viele
kinder und jugendliche nicht mehr
zumutbar und ich kann ihnen nicht
zustimmen von knox haben gesagt die
kinder sind genau so infektiös in der
übertragung des virus wie die
erwachsenen
ja herr trotzdem hat die untersuchung
gemacht aber in der fläche muss man
sagen wir sehen das nicht so dass die
hauptüberträger die kinder und
jugendlichen sind sondern es oder die
älteren jugendlichen vielleicht schon
aber die die kinder sicher nicht doch
nicht
den würde ich gerne auch mal mit
aufnehmen also diese anderen folgen also
das was jetzt gerade auch noch von frau
doktor bruder geschildert wurde also die
psychosozialen folgen
das maß getragen über einen längeren
zeitraum wird das von ihnen nicht so
streng gesehen oder welche haltung haben
sie dazu
also ich glaube die psychosozialen
folgen die frau braun hat gerade
angesprochen hat bezogen sich jetzt
nicht speziell aufs macht getragen
sondern bezogen sich darauf dass kinder
mit ich sage mal
psychologischen oder psychischen
problemen
in die ambulanz und kommen und das dann
nicht so richtig feststellbar sei ob es
sich dabei um longo wird oder
wenn ich dann kurz mal
dass man die maske die ganze zeit in der
schule auch auffahrt auch im unterricht
auf hat und dass es kinder gibt in der
grundschule die noch gar kein unterricht
quasi ohne maske kennengelernt haben ja
natürlich also es gibt natürlich also
ich freue mich auch nicht darüber dass
mein kind den ganzen tag so eine maske
im gesicht das ist völlig klar es ist
auch unbestritten dass das dass der
unterricht schwieriger ist dass die die
sprachentwicklung und und bei
fremdsprachen und so dieses argument
dass das ist klar das ist unumstritten
das ist wie gesagt es macht auch keinen
spaß die maske zu tragen aber noch
einmal jetzt kann ich umgehen als andere
reise jetzt schon um die immensen
entschuldigung ja es sind 1 strecke sind
einschränkungen natürlich aber auf der
anderen seite der waagschale liegt eine
tatsächlich gefährliche krankheit und
was sie sagen mit die die kinder kommen
mit mit depressiven verstimmungen und so
weiter in die ambulanzen und man könne
das nicht unterscheiden da habe ich ja
eben schon etwas zugesagt es geht
mittlerweile messungen es gibt
hirnregionen die man nachweisen die
nachweislich geschädigt werden es gibt
biomarker im blut die mini thrombosen
anzeigen es ist mittlerweile durch auch
durchaus nachweisbar und
ja aber frau nur da sind ja kein
hunderte seiten die jetzt in der fläche
hier an gewandelt wird sondern das sind
studien über einzelne studien über die
seda berichten das ist nichts was in der
fläche untersucht wird bei den kindern
und jugendlichen
und es ist einfach so wenn wir heute auf
die infizierten kinder und jugendlichen
gucken dann ist der großteil davon
bisher völlig folgenlos erkrankt das
heißt es ist ausgeheilt und sie sind
jetzt gesund nach allem was wir heute
wissen ich mache
ja offensichtlich dass es eine
unterschiedliche auffassung gibt in der
einschätzung vielleicht auch in der
abwägung der gegenüberstehenden güter
das ist ja auch legitim
ich würde gerne nochmal die schüler mit
in die ganze debatte einbeziehen wir
haben wir nachgefragt bei dario schramm
wie er die sache sieht er ist
generalsekretär der
bundesschülerkonferenz
viele sind natürlich der meinung dass
eine erleichterung ist dass die masken
wegfallen andere wiederum sehen
natürlich die gefahr gerade in den
klassenräumen profil noch umkämpft sind
dass man eben wieder viele quarantäne
fälle hat viele kinder können sich
anstecken ich glaube vor allem aber auch
dass viele selbst bei einem wegfall
freiwillig die maske noch weiter tragen
würden ich wünsche mir dass wir auf
jeden fall mehr wissenschaftliche
entscheidungen treffen und ich
politische entscheidungen gerade in den
letzten monaten haben wir viele
entscheidungen gemerkt in den schulen
die er politischer natur war was
gefährlich ist wenn es um den
infektionsschutz geht dann müssen wir
fallen noch einheitlich vorgehen weil
ich noch mal darauf plädieren dass sie
nicht jedes land jetzt macht was es will
und dann für mich ist noch ein ganz
anderer punkt sehr wichtig darf eben
auch nicht in vergessenheit geraten weil
das auch gerade eine große diskussion
ist wir dürfen vor allem auch jetzt wenn
wir darüber reden dass die massen weg
gehen eben mit dem testen nicht aufhören
in vielen bundesländern wird diskutiert
dass sie die test sozusagen nicht mehr
für die schule bezahlt werden das halte
ich für fatal
da verwundert da würde ich gerne noch
mal nachfragen auch bei ihnen weil in
ein ähnliches horn sozusagen auch karl
lauterbach der spd-gesundheitsexperte
gestoßen hat er hat auch gesagt die
masken pflicht kann wegfallen wenn man
je nach lage zwischen drei und fünf mal
die woche dann testen würde wäre das
denn dann mehr sinne ihres verbandes
naja dreimal getestet wird ja jetzt auch
schon na ja also das wäre jetzt
überhaupt nichts neues für die schüler
innen also es geht ja jetzt hier nicht
darum seien schnell unter susanne es ist
alles nicht so wild und na dann ist das
bundesland unterschiedlich auch in
niedersachsen wird dreimal getestet
wobei sie haben es jetzt um sie wenn es
jetzt auf zwei reduzieren
ja tatsächlich so man muss ja jetzt auch
nicht alles auf einmal fallen lassen
darum geht es nicht also es geht uns ja
überhaupt nicht darum jetzt zu sagen so
jetzt müssen die masken bleibt es wird
nicht mehr getestet abstände wenn nicht
mehr eingeschaltet wir tun jetzt so als
wäre nichts darum geht es nicht aber wir
müssen jetzt einen schritt weiter kommen
und
in dem wissen dass wir und von noch da
sind wir offensichtlich anderer
meinungen ja aber das was wir in unseren
praxen wahrnehmen sehen wir nicht viele
schwer erkrankte kinder und auch nicht
viele kinder die mit folgen erkranken
muss man jetzt anfangen und muss alters
gestaffelt anfangen die maske
wegzulassen im unterricht wenn man dann
sagt wir testen erst noch mal weiter um
auf der sicheren seite zu sehen und die
instanzen weiter verfolgt die
krankenhaus belegung weiter verfolgt
dann sollte es möglich sein zu einer
lockerung auch für alle anderen
altersgruppen in den schulen zu kommen
und dann wenn man merkt wir haben es
hier tatsächlich mit einem geringen
infektionsgeschehen zu tun und wir
werden es sehen auch frau bringt man hat
schon vieles vorhergesagt was dann doch
etwas anders eingetreten ist ja wir
haben alle von den virologen im ohr was
wir für ins identen auch über den sommer
haben werden es hat sich nicht
bewahrheitet es ist so keiner hat bei
dieser erkrankung die weisheit mit
löffeln gefressen das muss man doch ganz
klar sagen wir wissen es letztlich alle
nicht genau aber mit allem was wir
bisher wissen wir hatten oder erfahrung
ehrlicher sicht was die folgen der
erkrankung angeht ja eben genau
vielleicht wir haben wir haben etwas für
mich
eine massive del tabelle hinter sich mit
erschreckenden infektionszahlen unter
schülern und jugendlichen mit instanzen
die ich weiß nicht ein bisschen welche
zahlen drauf ging ich glaube noch mehr
noch weitaus mehr als die 800er
insidious die wir in wuppertals und zeit
lang hatten und da hat das haben die cdc
also dass die centers of disease control
heißt es haben studien gemacht die ganz
eindeutig zeigen dass dort in den
schulen wo die masken nicht waren sind
die stelle sind die fälle doppelt so
schnell gestiegen und die
wahrscheinlichkeit für einen ausbruch
bei den nicht masken schulen war 3,5 mal
höher also wir müssen nicht das ist das
was ich immer der deutschen politik zur
vorwerfe dass man immer sagt wir warten
mal ab und bei uns wird's schon nicht
passieren wir müssen doch nur in die
nachbarländer schauen wir müssen nun
nach großbritannien schauen wir müssen
ja aber es ist in der tat und die stehen
nämlich dass auch die aussagen der frau
wurde anschließend wie wichtig ihr
verband und auch andere verbände immer
gerne berufen
nach denen jetzt ja auch eine neue
studie nach denen der senat in berlin
beschlossen hat und der hygiene beirat
bei beschlossen haben dass die masken
unnötig sind weil das incident risiko
sind niedrig für das infektionsrisiko
niederzierer an den schulen diese
studien wurden zum teil durchgeführt zu
zeiten als die schulen geschlossen waren
und da wirklich da fällt mir nicht also
eine nochmalig
wir uns mit den usa würde mich beide
gleichzeitig jetzt bitte wieder frau
wundert
also mit den usa können wir uns wirklich
nur sehr eingeschränkten vergleichen
auch was die schwere der infektion bei
den kindern und jugendlichen angeht die
usa hat ein ganz anderes
gesellschaftssystem es sind andere
ethnische voraussetzungen und dann haben
wir tatsächlich die erfahrung gemacht
dass das scheinbar einen großen effekt
was die schwere der erkrankung angeht
hat und viel mehr schweres übergewicht
bei kindern jugendlichen viel mehr
schlecht eingestellte asthma dass die
gesundheitliche versorgung der kinder
und jugendlichen in den usa um längen
schlechter ist als bei uns also andere
risikofaktoren die da auch eine rolle
stehen wir uns das mal ganz wohl nicht
so vergleichen können da ja ganz gut ja
eine zäsur an dieser stelle müsse und
der dennoch mussten sie uns nach denen
machen ja ich muss an meine nicht nach
dänemark ich muss vor allem jetzt noch
mal auf unsere community schauen denn
wir nehmen ja auch immer gerne noch ein
paar user mit coole pommes über youtube
schreibt ist eine stufen masken pflicht
sinnvoll wie in anderen bundesländern
zum beispiel dass die erste bis siebte
klasse keine maske tragen muss darüber
dann alleine tragen müssen die frage an
frau dr
was meinen sie
es wäre etwas was ich mir gut vorstellen
könnte dass man sagt lasst uns doch mit
den kleinen erstmal anfangen und gucken
auf der anderen seite könnte man auch
sagen ja wenn wir unter umständen in der
oberstufe ganze kohorten die sitzen in
der klasse und diesen zweig ja die sind
entweder genesene sind alle durchgeimpft
auch da kann man natürlich darüber
diskutieren warum müssen die da jetzt
noch eine maske tragen während sie
abends in der kneipe zusammensitzen und
haben keine mehr auf aber ich finde wenn
man sagt lasst uns erst mal anfangen
lasst uns mit bestimmten altersgruppen
anfangen das ist ja auch das was unser
präsident des berufsverbands genau so
gesagt hat altersabhängig gucken immer
natürlich auch auf die zahlen der
inzidenz gucken auf die schwere der
verläuft dann ist das etwas womit man
starten kann und was denke ich ein gutes
signal an die kinder und jugendlichen
ist noch eine nachfrage dazu von chris
ebay youtube ein haken da
ja bitte forward ganz kurz weil die frau
bähnert immer gerne ihren verband jetzt
als beispiel anführt möchte ich gerne
als gegenbeispiele anführen welche
verbände alle für das beibehalten der
das masken tragen an schulen sind das bh
das ist die whu das ist das lka das ist
die deutsche gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendmedizin
das ist die american academy of
pediatrics
verzeihen sie das sind die cdc in den
usa das ist die gew bunt und sie
brauchen nicht alle aktien also sind auf
jeden fall
also das haben wir
überhaupt
zusammen es ist umstritten oder sind wir
wieder in dem fonds berlins das ist die
große frage
tja nun also ich nehme an dieser stelle
jetzt gerne zur kenntnis dass sie sagen
okay es ist unausgewogen wir haben
trotzdem jetzt das gespräch mit ihnen
beiden weil wir denken es ist schon eine
position die ebenfalls hörenswert ist
die vdr brunner dort vertritt und an sie
würde ich auch gerne noch mal jetzt eine
frage stellen denn chris über youtube
fragt hat man denn untersucht wie oft
die kinder die gleiche maske tragen und
was passiert wenn sie die ganze zeit die
gleiche maske tragen würden weil
vielleicht im haushalt kann darauf
achtet dass sie die wechseln ist die da
noch genauso effektiv vermutlicher nicht
vermutlich nicht nein also nein das weiß
ich nicht ob das an den schulen
kontrolliert wird ob die kinder mit
frische maske aufsetzen ich wage es zu
bezweifeln dass es in vielen haushalten
gesteht geschieht es wird nach wie vor
auch oft eine alltags maske aufgesetzt
bei den kindern und jugendlichen oder
bei den kindern vor allen dingen bei den
jugendlichen weniger also das ist
natürlich so dass der schutzfaktor wenn
die maske durchnässt ist einfach nicht
mehr so gut da ist und auch die
kompetenz mit der eine maske getragen
wird ist sicherlich deutlich besser
geworden wir haben jetzt noch unheimlich
viele monate pandemie anderthalb jahre
hinter uns das sind dinge die die kinder
natürlich auch gelernt haben und
trotzdem ist es so je jünger die kinder
sind umso häufiger wird die maske
runtergezogen damit man sich ins gesicht
fassen kann oder sie hängt sowieso unter
der nase das ist halt auch wenn nichts
was man selten sieht und da muss man
wirklich sagen ja das ist für die
kleinen natürlich schwieriger vor ort
noch mal auch an sie eine zuschauerfrage
jungen i as schreibt die masken pflicht
für kinder sofort beenden seine meinung
oder ihre meinung ist darf nicht sein
dass die leute wie früher feiern und
zusammen sind also die erwachsenen in
dem fall während kinder in einer so
wichtigen phase ihrer entwicklung
derartig belastet werden was entgegnen
sie dieser position von work
dieser position entgegne ich dass
erstens die menschen die jetzt
ausgelassen feiern können geimpft oder
genesen sind das sind die kinder nicht
und auch hier wieder mein argument die
ich hatte die belastung durch eine maske
zwar für real aber es ist da weitaus
kleinere übel zu dem was das ohne maske
geschehen kann nämlich infektion und die
dementsprechenden schäden das ist
einfach das hält sich nicht die waage
frau wundert haben sie auch noch eine
bemerkung dazu
ich habe also ich glaube die argumente
sind gefallen ich könnte mich jetzt nur
wiederholen
wir sehen schon eine beeinträchtigung
der kinder und jugendlichen ob es jetzt
immer direkt durch die maske ist oder
durch die vielen anderen einschränkungen
in der pandemie das ist manchmal schwer
auseinanderzuhalten ich glaube da muss
man ehrlich sein es ist eine gemengelage
die man einfach beobachtet und wir
beobachten sie mit sorge
das verstehe ich und ich glaube das
verstehen auch unsere zuschauer und user
von jörg aber ich glaube auch ihre
position ist sehr deutlich geworden ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich für eine ja
bitte doch doch sie dürfen noch mal ich
würde wenn ich noch eine eine letzte
sache anmerken
dass ich es ganz wichtig findet dann
oder dass ich es sehr schade findet dass
immer gegeneinander ausgespielt wird
schule ist wichtig bildung ist wichtig
das soziale miteinander ist wichtig und
dann der gesundheitsschutz und das wird
so gegeneinander ausgespielt wie gesagt
ich habe ja auch ein kind ich bin heute
hier als als als mutter die ihr kind
geschützt sehen möchte vor krankheit die
aber auch möchte dass ihr kind weiter in
die schule gehen kann und wenn wir
möchten dass die schulen offen bleiben
sind wir möchten dass die schulen sicher
sind wenn wir auch möchten das nicht
wieder hunderte tausende kinder in
quarantäne gehen dann ist ja die maske
einfach ein
kleines hilfsmittel was dazu führen kann
dass eben bildung und soziales
miteinander auch weiter läuft das ist
mir wichtig dass es nicht so ist
entweder schulen zu oder das sondern da
so das richtige gesundheitsschutz
brauchen um eine sichere bildungswerk
ich denke das ist ein schlusswort auf
das vor uns verständigen kann man sagen
ich bin des rentenalters messungen weil
wir uns da völlig einig sind wunderbar
das freut mich der moderator hat es ja
auch gerne persönlich am ende ich danke
ihnen beiden sehr herzlich für dieses
lebhafte gespräche und ich denke ihre
positionen sind sehr deutlich geworden
dann auch nochmal unseren usern herzlich
fürs mitmachen die kommentare und
wünsche allen einen guten abend und
hoffentlich eine gesunde nächste zeit
dankeschön und für euch auch alles gute
und bis morgen hoffentlich bis dann
zschau